Leonard fournette ran for 225 he didn't
score though just the fourth player
all-time to run for at least 220 yards
and not score a touchdown way I'm going
negative here I shouldn't be going
negative it was an unbelievable
performance against the Broncos once
Leonard fournette
joins us now good morning Leonard how
are you come on how you doing I'm doing
okay
when does the pain starts start to set
in after all those carries a game like
that I think as soon as you take your
paddle what hurts today you know you
just saw it you know so surrounded you
know what a game like that your body
really don't start recovering or you
don't start feeling back moments are
like a Thursday you know so right now
it's all about so can you know
listen Union legs back under you kendo
club back back flooring and I'm just
taking care about it
when's the last time you got hit you
went wow that's a little different that
really hurts good for you
I figured you know you got von miller
and those guys on the other side that
somebody was gonna put a pop on you know
I had Jerome Bettis telling me a couple
years ago that when he would run his
style was he wanted to hear the
defensive back like you know he would
like a whimper like a girl that's what
buss said you ever hear that from a guy
who's trying to tackle you sometimes you
know it depends it depends on a guy you
know I mean we're what we're big back
soon are you following this new college
law they're trying to put into play the
pay for play in California I think South
Carolina is now going to sign it Florida
is going to New York so the athlete
would be able to have their image and
their likeness you would be able to
control that I mean man I'm all I'm all
for cuz I remember I was in college
and she definitely wouldn't let me and
well not me my family's to sell my
clothing line I made up so I mean I'm
all for it you know
I don't come from a rich family anything
like that
you know so just try to make with your
family so I mean I have no problem with
it what the NCAA say about it Leonard
that they would not well we were doing
it and it was like we made we made some
money off it but when they found out we
had to give all the money back no boy
because I was wondering if you were
coming out of high school and you were
the number one recruit in the nation
according to ESPN your five-star recruit
and you could go to a school that would
allow you to capitalize let's say USC or
you know Florida Gators but LSU wasn't
going to allow you to capitalize on that
wouldn't that have changed your decision
of where you were going to play yeah but
they could pay a lot of money I mean if
you I mean boosters could pay your money
local businesses you could have your own
shoe I mean I there's a lot of things
that you could probably do and I'm you
know I'm wondering how athletes are
going to be able to cash in on them at
same time you know I'm for it but got
absolutely you're trying not to be small
with that too you know also about you
know managing the money you know who's
gonna be over the money you know cuz you
know your college your young most most
of that was something 18 whatever the
case may be love buying stuff the newer
stuff the newest things to have so it's
a lot a lot that plays into that if not
LSU where were you going Oh
Alabama ooh how tough was that call to
Coach Saban you know both of the former
well whose burns still there but Frank
listen we all went to the same high
school high schools and Augusta High
School in New Orleans and man it was it
was it was tough for me and I noticed
that you got into a heated discussion
with the former Alabama Crimson Tide cam
Robinson late in the game what was that
about
oh you know I didn't want to making a
just a crazy mistake cost us the game to
get out of Hill suitable range
but we all good now I made up better
place and uh you know that's my god we
both came in together you know it's too
uh too great at least this one went
I'm gonna guess he can eat a lot of
donors that might have been expensive
for you Leonard how goofy is Gardner
Minshew
is he goofy in the huddle at all no no
no I mean he's a laid back laid back
type of diet you know uh his composure
he has on the field you know the spite
of whatever whatever we have gone on or
the situation he were he remained the
same I noticed you're catching more
passes this year was that by design in
the offseason not really I guess coach
look I will see he wants to just open
the ball up I mean it spread the ball
around it's you everyone that uh would
not dissing run anything with the past
that we can pass the ball to yeah it
feels like you know that's what they're
asking running backs to do I I don't
know like just a straight-ahead runner
you know that seems to be obsolete in
the NFL now you feel like if you're
gonna play that position you got to be
able to run but you also have to be able
to catch passes you know it's not
there's not back in the day I used to be
you know like you know muscle Pharm I
think one of the first guys to really
open up or thought that um it hey ma'am
its Mitch again my name is a ball so you
know it's kind of tearing it's a thing
now for all the back how's the family
are they good my kids are doing great
mom that brother sisters everybody in
your daughter's lyric
yeah lyric I love that name who came up
with it
Oh me that's good my son my son my son
is before oh he's gonna beat Leonard the
fourth ya know lengthen hey congrats on
the game pretty impressive there with
the Broncos and good luck against the
Panthers we appreciate your time that's
Leonard fournette
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on directiy
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]